good afternoon my name is harry attredge
chairman this year of the dwight h terry
lectureship committee and i'm delighted
to welcome you to this very special
celebration
the terry lectureship was established
about a century ago
by a gift from dwight harrington terry
of bridgeport connecticut to endow a
series of lectures on religion and its
application to human welfare in the
light of scientific knowledge and
philosophical insights
these lectures have produced a long
series of distinguished books published
by yale university press and to
celebrate that longer distinguished
history
we've decided this year to have a very
special celebration with five
distinguished lecturers
at a panel which is going to be chaired
by margaret warner
newly on the yale corporation
so we welcome you to this this series
this is an interactive event and if you
have questions or issues that would you
would like to raise with our lecturers
you may do so through the yale website
www.yale.edu slash terry lecture
the format today will be
a series of lectures followed by
questions and answers we will take a
brief break at 3 30 and be back for the
second lecture of the afternoon at 4. we
will conclude promptly
in time for us to leave this room by 5
30 this evening for reception upstairs
in room 208. we need to leave because
there is a special screening in this
room this evening and the room has to be
cleared at that time
at this point to introduce our first
lecturer i'd like to call on my
colleague
in religious studies and sociology phil
gorsky who works on the very timely
issue of religion and politics
thank you very much it's a great
pleasure and honor for me to be able to
introduce
robert whatnow who is professor of
sociology and chair of the sociology
department at princeton university
and i think it would be fair to say that
he is the most prominent sociologist of
religion working in the united states
today
i'd add that he's also one of the most
prolific
he's written dozens of books edited
dozens more and written scores and
scores of articles in fact one of my
colleagues once equipped to me that she
was going to have to stop reading all
the things that bob was writing so that
she could get some of her own writing
done
i wouldn't recommend that because i
think there are a few
people in the united states today who
have their pulse
on
american
religious life
the way that professor what now does
he's worked on a wide number of topics
including relations between evangelicals
and liberals
popular religion and spirituality
the role of arts and music
in contemporary christianity just to
name a few and today he is going to
start us off in our dialogue about
religion and science
well thank you i appreciate the
opportunity to be here today
it's impressive when you think about it
that the terry lectures began about 100
years ago and
that the conflict that we think about
between religion and science is still as
important as it was
way back then
today to start us off i want to take a
rather
unorthodox approach to this topic
i'm going to focus on those folks who
see no conflict
between religion and science
and just to give you a brief preview of
where i'm going with this i'm going to
spend the first part of my
lecture trying to explain some of the
reasons why there should be
conflict between religion and science
and then discuss some of the reasons why
there isn't more conflict than there is
so as has been
announced my topic is no contradictions
here
science religion and the culture of all
reasonable possibilities
in seeking perspective on recent
controversies about religion and science
one can hardly do better than the wisdom
provided by that bible of guidance and
revelation for academics the new york
times
in its coverage of litigation about the
teaching of intelligent design
and of school board decisions about
evolution
and of policy debates about stem cell
research and genetic engineering the
nation's favorite arbiter of elite
opinion
has documented beyond doubt that
questions about the respective roles of
science and religion remain of great
public interest
it is this public interest
or more precisely the cultural role
of these controversies on which i wish
to focus
what fascinates me about the new york
times coverage is not its reportage or
even its editorials
but the letters it chooses to print from
its readers
unsurprisingly many of the letters speak
in favor of science
while others side clearly with religion
the former variously associate science
with hard evidence discovery and
progressive thinking
in contrast with the ludicrous
disheartening
and even dangerous claims of religious
ideologues
the latter question whether scientific
facts are as firmly established as
scientists claim and worry about the
moral implications of science
a few accuse scientists of promoting an
agenda of unfettered atheism
but far more interesting are the letters
that seek to reconcile science and
religion
for example a reader from minneapolis
writes
in my view there is no contradiction
between evolution and religion
one explains how and the other explains
why
a scientist in los angeles observes
scientists science is a tool for
furthering human understanding of the
natural world
and as such can co-exist with religion
a reader in new jersey elaborates
science is about the natural material
world
religion is about the supernatural and
spiritual
science operates mainly with numbers
religion with words
and this reader concludes in short they
are separate but equal
well these readers are the voices of
reason
the defenders of a middle ground
threatened as much by the simplistic
proponents of science as by the radical
claims of religious extremists
theirs is a both and rather than an
either or world
and they are in distinguished company
they stand with albert einstein who
famously remarked science without
religion is lame religion without
science is
blind and with stephen j gould who has
argued that science tells us what the
universe is made of
while religion deals with ultimate
meaning and moral value
they rise above the fray so to speak
refusing to opt for the predefined
positions presented to them instead
preferring to question the very terms in
which the debate has been cast
they are what we train our students at
yale and princeton to be they are
capable of seeing both sides of an
argument
of parsing what at first appear to be
irreconcilable views
and thus transforming black and white
into shades of gray
their approach is so attractive
so thoroughly educated
and so reassuringly american
it has not been popular at least in my
discipline in sociology
for scholars to be interested in
studying people who espouse a language
of moderation
and reason
that language is too much our own to
feel comfortable examining it critically
the popular tactic is to start from the
supposition that proponents on the
religious side of these and most other
arguments
are so downright strange
as to deserve most of our attention
thus we dig a bit
and find that they are really expressing
some economic or political grievance
that they are too dumb to recognize
themselves
or worse are being led astray by clever
political operatives or
self-aggrandizing religious leaders
for instance in his book what's the
matter with kansas thomas frank
a native of that state who fled to the
big time in chicago
argues that kansans vote republican
because they are obsessed with keeping
evolution out of their schools and
putting prayer back in
whereas voting democrat would be better
for their state's economy
jayhawkers are bargaining away the
chance to give their children a better
future he says by focusing more
attention on moral battles than on good
jobs and better schools
thomas frank is perhaps not the best
example of serious scholarship since his
book is candidly autobiographical and
impressionistic
yet it is worth noting that his work has
been warmly embraced in the social
science community
a more thoroughly academic example can
be found in the work of sociologist amy
binder whose book contentious curricula
examines creationist controversies
binder argues that creationists are
cleverer than the naive reader may have
supposed
leaders frame a technical sociological
term here leader's frame appeals in
religious terms when speaking to church
groups but downplay this rhetoric when
talking to the media or in the courts
they strategize and mobilize against
school boards
rather than against larger governing
bodies because it takes fewer resources
to do so
it helps she says when they win
elections to these boards it hurts when
school administrators muscle
creationists decide with assertions
about separation of church and state
it's understandable that scholars focus
on what they perceive as deviant
behavior
the very idea of a few citizens in out
of the way places like kansas or dover
pennsylvania promoting strange ideas
since journalists and social scientists
scurrying
to study this quaint phenomenon
it is as if the amish suddenly ran a
candidate for president
what would the world be like if these
creationists whom their own neighbors
describe as the laughingstock of the
world
succeeded in eliminating science from
the curriculum
perhaps there is something to be learned
here about the peculiarities of american
culture
just as there is from studying serial
killers
if the goal is to understand american
culture it would nevertheless seem
strange to focus on the periphery and
neglect the center
the both and position expressed in
thoughtful letters to the editor is held
by a large share of the american public
in opinion polls this middle ground is
favored by a majority or large minority
of the public depending on the wording
of specific questions
for instance a cbs news survey conducted
in 2005 found that 67 percent of the
public believes it is possible to
believe in both god and creation uh
sorry both god and evolution while only
29 thought this was not possible
the sheer reasonableness of the both and
approach though
necessarily raises two interesting
puzzles
first why is it that science and
religion appear to be in conflict at all
is it that the antagonists who
perpetrate these struggles are less
reasonable than everybody else
is it perhaps true that they are simply
duped by their leaders
if it is so sensible to argue that
science and religion are simply
different
would it not be more likely that
conflict between the two would be
non-existent
pursuing these questions will provide a
way of examining afresh why religion and
science
might not be so easily reconciled even
for reasonable people
once we have considered these
possibilities though a different puzzle
arises
why are the conflicts between science
and religion as infrequent as they are
this question will take us into the
larger terrain of contemporary culture
where we can view the assumptions that
undergird our conviction that reasonable
people can simply resolve their
differences if they bring enough gray
matter to the table
a useful place to begin is the idea
commonly known in sociological theory as
institutional differentiation
the idea of institutional
differentiation simply put
is that the various spheres of social
life
are more distinct and specialized now
than they probably were in earlier times
when societies were smaller and less
complex
for instance max weber argued that one
of the important preconditions for the
rise of modern capitalism was the
separation of paid labor from the
household
this separation of spheres faber
suggested made it possible for labor to
be governed with greater attention to
rewarding productivity than was the case
when workers were also family members
the emergence of modern science in 17th
century europe is typically regarded as
another example of institutional
differentiation
although its rise may have been
facilitated by religion
science then became an autonomous sphere
capable of setting its own agenda and
determining for itself what activities
are worth pursuing
if science and religion are distinct
institutions then this is further reason
to believe that potential conflict can
be overcome by recognizing their
differences
these are not merely conceptual
differences such as one of emphasizing
the natural or supernatural
but also of social arrangements
themselves in the simplest case
scientific academies do science and
religious organizations do religion
scientists do not preach and preachers
are ill-suited to conduct scientific
research
of course it might be objected that
greater specialization requires greater
interaction
across spheres a point that daniel
durkheim emphasized in describing the
organic solidarity that arises from
people with different occupations
becoming interdependent
but that argument needs to be pushed
further
a baker and a butcher might be mutually
dependent
but it's less clear that science and
religion bear the same relationship to
one another
a better analogy would be two
all-purpose delis
one specializing in bread and the other
in meat
but both of them seeking to expand
science and religion come into conflict
because neither one stays
neatly in its respective sphere
as jilly s drory and his co-authors
observe in their recent empirical study
of the global expansion of science as a
cultural form and i quote a reasonable
way to interpret the long history of
conflict between scientific and
religious models
is to see these institutions as
competing on the same ground
rather than operating in different
domains
as science has grown its autonomy has
been compromised by the very fact that
it influences more aspects of social
life
and in turn is dependent on a wider
array of social economic and political
resources
the patronage that supported kepler's
observatory in denmark
for galileo's research in italy where
the royal society in london and the
french academy of sciences in paris
came from royal coffers or from the
medici
and from other wealthy individuals such
as the dukes of savoy and tuscany
only much later did governments require
average citizens to support science
through taxes
and to expose their children to science
in public schools
the advance of science was an act not
only of intellectual achievement but
also of political displacement
the three estates of the realm
wrote don k price in his memorable
account of this transition
were the clergy the nobility and the
burgesses
the privileges of all three were
abolished
but now price observed the results of
scientific advance have been to to
require federal support of education and
the appropriation of a tithe
of the federal budget for research and
development
the idea that science merely describes
the natural world leaving questions
about purpose and worth to religion is
simply untrue
the sharp rise in developing nations
initiation of government-sponsored
science ministries and participation in
international scientific organizations
illustrates the extent to which being
modern and progressive require at least
a symbolic commitment to science
being an educated person does not
require knowing anything about religion
but it does involve taking courses in
science
passing examinations testing one's
familiarity with scientific thinking
and being respectful towards science in
one's work and of course at parties
in these ways science shapes the
cultural norms that serve as standards
of self-worth
personal identity is deeply influenced
in other ways by scientific discoveries
the meaning of human personhood is
profoundly shaped by how humanity itself
is located in an evolutionary chain
or in an expanding view of nearly
infinite galaxies
for its part religion
may appear in many instances to be in
retreat
but it too expands periodically out of
its earlier domain
the role of darwinism in the rise of
late 19th century protestant
fundamentalism is a commonly cited
example
fundamentalism was as surely an attempt
to be scientific as it was an effort to
resist science
millenarian predictions about the
fulfillment of biblical prophecies
gained popularity as these arguments
relied more heavily on numeric
calculations
and new certainties about the orderly
progression of time
during the 1950s religious organizations
drew significantly from the social
sciences especially from psychology
and from the expanding mental health
movement as they develop new and more
highly specialized programs of pastoral
counseling
the more recent emergence of creation
science as it's called and of arguments
about intelligent design borrowing as
they do from scientific studies and from
critical discussions within the
scientific literature
could be considered another such example
the interaction that results when
science and religion expand into each
other's turf
is more complex even than this image of
competition implies
because the boundaries defining the two
spheres are themselves matters of
negotiation
what thomas f guerin a sociologist
calls boundary work
consists of scientists ongoing efforts
to create a favorable public image for
science
by contrasting it favorably to
non-scientific intellectual or technical
activities
in victorian england
for instance
kieran notes that scientists publicly
ridiculed church leaders who prayed for
god's intervention after the cholera
epidemic of 1866
and they denounced prayer as a form of
superstition
and charged the church with standing in
the way of scientific progress
garen suggests that religion bashing
actually served scientists well
meaning that in a convoluted way
religion as an enemy of science is also
its friend
rather than depicting religion as
something different from science but
useful in its own way
scientists characterized it as
pseudoscience based on false empirical
claims
that such uses of religion by scientists
continue is readily apparent
writing in the new york times
evolutionary biologist olivia judson
argued recently
that an understanding of evolution was
vital to guarding against a flu pandemic
and in her words saving the lives of
tens of millions of people
by implication religionists themselves
might be responsible if a flu pandemic
did occur
let's not strip evolution from the
textbooks she wrote or banish it from
the class or replace it with ideologies
born of wishful thinking
if we do
we might find ourselves facing the
consequences of natural selection
boundary work
suggests conscious and even malicious
manipulation at times of the turf wars
between religion and science
it is also the case though that boundary
questions become important because
definitions of religion and of science
are themselves subjects of cultural
construction
for instance popular assertions about
religion typically assume that it is
readily defined by belief in god
or resort in some other way to arguments
about the supernatural
yet scholars of religion seldom define
it in those terms
clifford geertz's well-worn definition
of religion for example refers neither
to god nor to the supernatural but
emphasizes symbols
powerful and long-lasting motivations
and conceptions of a general order of
existence
clothed in an aura of factuality
would that definition not apply equally
to some understandings of science
lest it be assumed that religion is
somehow unique in being subject to such
definitional ambiguities
it is worth noting that science too has
come under scrutiny for the same reasons
what counts as scientific fact is by no
means dictated only by nature itself
scientific activity is not about nature
bruno latour and steve wolgar write in
their influential ethnographic study of
laboratory life
it is a fierce fight to construct
reality they say
they do not mean that scientists falsify
their observations or that they
fabricate reality from thin air they do
show through numerous examples how
scientific conclusions are influenced by
the availability or unavailability of
instruments how powerful teams impose
standards that may reduce the ability of
other teams to compete
and how tentative statements preclude
the possibility of pursuing other
reasonable lines of investigation
the upshot of these examples is that
neither science nor religion can be
quite as easily compartmentalized into
separate and non-competing domains as
our both and commentators want to
believe
it is the case that ambiguous conceptual
categories can be the starting place for
more nuanced arguments about
similarities and differences
however the more relevant point is that
ambiguity also opens the door for
continuing conflict
it is simply impossible to look back at
some historic event
and conclude that the debate between
religion and science was finally
resolved at that point
as long as the two have fuzzy edges
proponents antagonists bystanders in the
general public will be able to contest
where one domain should end and the
other begin
the likelihood of such contestation
increases as i have suggested because
religion and science are never static
indeed both struggle to assert
themselves as legitimate ways of
addressing important issues
and thus as legitimate claimants of
social resources
now there's another source of conflict
that
i will
introduce by mentioning briefly
something from paul recur
may remember that paul recur wrote about
what he called a hermeneutics of
suspicion
and
in his framing that was usually
associated with a critique of religion
as
such as one finds in
marx or nietzsche or freud
and rickor argued that these masters of
suspicion as he called them
unveiled the illusory character of
religion by showing that it concealed
political and economic interests
to see reality clearly recur argued one
needed to unmask the false perceptions
of religion at least these masters of
suspicion argued that
but an interesting thing has happened in
our time
it might be argued now that this same
skeptical attitude toward religion has
also extended
towards science
power and privilege most certainly lie
with the scientific estate as much today
as they did with religion in the past
the high esteem in which the public
holds scientists and science if polls
are believed
is tempered with the populist
ambivalence that colors public attitudes
toward all elites
admiration bleeds easily into envy and
further into disdain
if a segment of the religious community
stands ready to battle science over
evolution and genetic engineering
this broader hermeneutics of suspicion
toward science is almost certainly a
predisposing factor
science is sometimes popularly regarded
as the great savior
bringing hope for conquering illnesses
and inventing labor-saving technology
but its image has also been tarnished
critical discussions of science seldom
pass up the opportunity to connect it
with the development of the atomic bomb
in medical research the infamous
tuskegee experiment in which some 400
poor black men were never told they had
syphilis and never treated for it all in
the name of research that's often
mentioned as well
environmental concerns have also
affected public perceptions of science
ever since the publication of rachel
carson's silent spring in the 1960s
former nsf director richard atkinson
recalls
there was a growing feeling abroad that
the purity of science was not quite as
pure as it had seemed
an additional factor that aggravates the
potential conflict between religion and
science
is that relatively few scientists
are religious
at least in conventional ways
for instance in a recent national survey
of physicists chemists and biologists at
elite research universities
only eight percent said they had no
doubts about god's existence while 38
said they did not believe in god at all
and another 29 said they did not know if
there is a god and believe there was no
way to find out
in the same survey
55 said they had no religious
affiliation
while only 16 percent attended religious
services
even as often as once a month
these figures underscore the sharp
differences that exist between
scientists and the general public where
for instance only seven percent can be
regarded as atheists or agnostics
if the public imagines that scientists
personal views influence their
scholarship
then perceptions of conflict between
religion and science would not be
surprising
a further confounding aspect of the
relationship between religion and
science is what is sometimes referred to
as the hubris of science
having considered einstein's remark
about the complementarities of religion
and science earlier
we need also to recall
abraham heschel's rejoinder
heschel said hubris is the tragic sin of
our time
it is the conviction that there exist
only laws of nature and technology
heschel's view is currently echoed in
internet blogs where this perception of
science surfaces freely
one blogger writes i'm skeptical of
scientists and technologists designing
animals or genes or drugs or anything
else that nature already does perfectly
in this blogger's view scientists are
drunk on hubris in it for the money or
their own glory
and sadly incapable of any humility
a less emotionally tinged argument
emerges in the writing of annie dillard
the prize-winning
author of pilgrimage at tinker creek
a book that was widely praised for its
extraordinary sensitivity to the
complexity of the natural world
in her more recent book
for the time being
dillard and adds a more explicitly
theological cultural and historical
dimension to her reflections
noting that our time has produced many
scientific advances such as antibiotics
silicon chips men on the moon and splice
genes dillard asks
are not our heightened times the
important ones
she might have added that after eons of
evolution suddenly we through the
explorations of science are now the
first ever to have grasped that process
surely science has taught us so much in
the last century
that we could not possibly be wrong
about what we know
do we not therefore have good reason to
think that our time is especially
significant
her answer
these times of hours are ordinary times
a slice of life like any other
and she asks who can bear to hear this
or who will consider it
perceptions of scientific hubris remind
us that cultural disputes with science
are by no means limited to those
involving religion
the two cultures that cp snow described
in the 1950s were not science and
religion but science in the humanities
or more specifically literary
intellectuals
snow is generally interpreted as having
argued for greater interaction between
science and the humanities
thus being a supporter of the both and
view
but his remarks about science also
convey understated criticism
the scientific culture he wrote is
expansive not restrictive confident at
the roots the more confident after its
bout of oppenheimerian self-criticism
certain that history is on its side
impatient intolerant
snow's concerns continue to be voiced in
larger criticisms about the moral
fragmentation of a culture in which the
can-do attitude of science presumably
overwhelms questions about deeper values
noting contemporary society's assumption
that every problem facing mankind is
susceptible to technological
intervention and control
roger kimball writes for instance that
quote the temptation to reduce culture
to a reservoir of titillating pastimes
is all but irresistible
in this critique science is not so much
the only source of cultural
deterioration
but is seen as a contributor to the
malays that includes drugs violence
promiscuity and an insatiable desire for
gratification
so those are some of the reasons why the
conflict between
science and religion might be expected
and having considered those let me now
turn to the second question
with such potential for conflict
why is it that the actual skirmishes
between science and religion have been
relatively rare
why is it that among the more than 14
000 school districts in the united
states only a few have become involved
in litigation about evolution and
intelligent design
with such a large number of religious
organizations and so many people in the
united states who believe in god and for
that matter in creationism
would it not have been reasonable to
expect a great deal more conflict with
science than there has been
what accounts for the fact that most
americans seem content to believe that
there are no contradictions between
science and religion
this capacity to look at the world in
both and terms is in my view the telling
feature of american culture
not the occasional fisticuffs between
religionists and scientists
let us acknowledge that the ease with
which we reconcile seemingly opposing
points of view may well be rooted in
something
more pervasive than american culture
itself
public opinion researchers have long
recognized that people give inconsistent
responses in surveys without feeling a
need to reconcile the apparent
contradictions
anthropologists have long argued that
one of the central features of tribal
rituals is their capacity to hold
intention
to seemingly opposing beliefs or
practices
cognitive dissonance theory though no
longer is uncritically accepted among
psychologists as it once was
asserts that people adjust their beliefs
when asked to perform tasks that deviate
from their values
the common thread in all of that
research is that the mind is malleable
and finds ways to create order or to
escape having to create order when
tension arises
yet the point i want to make
is not that people reconcile themselves
to seemingly contradictory beliefs or
statements about the world but how they
do this
how do they do this
the capacity to create consistency may
be cognitively available
but the manner in which this order
imposing process is carried out is
cultural in the case of both and views
about science and religion
resolution does not come by adjusting
one's views to be more compatible with
science or with religion
nor does it involve simply keeping the
two apart
the cultural work involved is more
complex
and although it includes specific ideas
about religion and science is also
associated with broader ways in which
our culture enables us to minimize
conflict
culture is above all language
and language provides the first means of
dealing with apparent contradictions
an example that i have examined in some
detail in another context
is the discursive negotiation of the
tension in american culture between
individualism on the one hand and
altruism on the other hand
the two are not mere opposites any more
than science and religion are but they
do run in opposing directions
individualism connotes looking out for
one's self-interest
whereas altruism means putting another's
needs ahead of one's own
but american culture manages to
emphasize both
how does it do that well in personal
interviews altruists who are also
individualistic
manage the potential conflict by
employing a number of discursive devices
one of the most common of which is
multi-vocality
literally speaking through the voice of
different characters
within the space of a few sentences
for instance a person might say
i help at the soup kitchen one night a
week and people there tell me you are
really a kind-hearted person but i say
no not really
i get a lot out of being here i have to
admit though sometimes i'd rather stay
home and relax
that's almost exactly a kind of quote
that i've heard number of times in real
life interviews
although these remarks are all under
uttered by one person
the different voices
involved permit the complexity of the
issues to be displayed
the speaker at once affirms that she
does engage in helping behavior yes
and is perceived by others as being
altruistic
but then she immediately denies being
purely altruistic
even while acknowledging that yes she is
also making a sacrifice
a multi-vocal statement like this seems
so effortless
that the conditions making it possible
can easily be missed
the fact of having had an exchange at a
soup kitchen is less important than
regarding the use of it as a legitimate
response to a question like that
the exchange substitutes for taking a
single position
on whether one is individualistic or
altruistic
it depends on a certain level of
flexibility
or even decoupling
of the various components of one's self
what psychologist kenneth gergen calls
multophrenia
or the splitting of the individual into
a multiplicity of self-investments
a multi-frantic person does not say
as martin luther did here i stand i can
do no other
instead there is a separation of roles
and of facets of the self to the point
that one can imagine taking several
different positions on a topic
and then engaging in a kind of internal
conversation among the proponents of
those different views that one
holds
it becomes possible to say for instance
i heard that albert einstein thought it
was possible to believe in god and to be
a scientist
so i suppose if i thought about it more
i might come to the same conclusion
although you could probably persuade me
otherwise if we talk long enough
in this respect multiphrenia means not
only being able to see different sides
of an argument
but actually being incapable of
arriving at a firm judgment of one's own
well real life examples of
multi-vocality and dealing with
questions about science and religion are
not hard to find
on october 24th 2005
the us district court transcript in kits
miller the
dover area school district much
publicized case that we're going to be
hearing more about
in these lectures today and tomorrow
the case in which the plaintiffs in
dover pennsylvania
and the school board
they sued
the school board for requiring the
criticisms of evolution based on ideas
of intelligent design be incorporated
into the curriculum
that transcript included the following
exchange between the plaintiff's
attorney mr walzack
and professor stephen fuller one of a
number of
expert witnesses this one happened to be
a sociologist that's why i decided to
pick on him
he was an expert witness on behalf of
the defense
so here's the question from the attorney
mr rothschild asked you a theory is not
going to graduate into effect right and
the answer was right exactly exactly
no i mean i do think there is that the
tone of this statement is a little
confusing
i mean so i'm agreeing with miller well
it was another witness on that point
now the lawyer's question is worthy and
interesting enough but listening to the
response that's from fuller
but what i'm agreeing with miller on is
i can understand why he sort of sees it
that way i wasn't necessarily saying
that i had some definitive view about
what the statement meant but rather that
i was sympathetic to you know
i could see where he was coming from in
finding this problematic
although the attorney persisted in
attempting to determine whether fuller
regarded evolution as theory fact or
some combination of the two
fuller continued to insist that he was
merely thinking through the issue
and naturally could see it from all
different angles
a dispersed self or a multiphrenic self
that incorporates different voices
provides a discursive mechanism for
reconciling religion and science
but in addition the normative emphasis
in our society on tolerance
provides a strong warrant
for doing so
alan wolf in his book one nation after
all
argues that middle class americans are
remarkably generous toward others who
may have profound differences of belief
so generous in fact
that they are likely to say
oh neat that's a cool view i'm glad you
said that
wolf's argument is especially relevant
to this question of conflict between
religion and science
because he concludes that the so-called
culture war
which pits fundamentalists against those
with more enlightened views does not
characterize
the majority
of americans instead the prevailing view
he says
is that we may have our differences but
we feel well we should abide by the law
and we should respect all points of view
wolf has been interpreted as suggesting
that american america consists largely
of a muddled middle
flanked by extremists on the right and
left
that rendering though misses the
subtlety of middle american culture
not only are diverse opinions tolerated
there's also a kind of tentativeness
even cynicism about truth
a person has difficulty holding fast to
a conviction because it is no longer
possible to know what is true
if this argument is correct the both and
position on science and religion is less
a statement about how the two are
complementary
and more a way of expressing uncertainty
about what either claims to provide
for instance in arguing that science
describes nature while religion deals
with questions of meaning and value
a person can in effect point to the
limitations of both science and religion
descriptions of nature are incomplete
disappointing even meaningless
and yet the big questions that religion
tries to answer may also be elusive
thus concerns about the hubris of
science do not take shape as convictions
about religion but as an unanswered
questions about the worth of scientific
knowledge
and similarly doubts about religion
remain as uncertainties
rather than translating into a devout
faith in science on the other side
in all of this understandings of
religion and science necessarily change
both become more highly personalized
although in different ways
when people associate religion with why
questions words the supernatural and the
spiritual
they do not mean that the biblical
account of creation should be taken
literally or that vatican teachings
about god are authoritative
they mean instead that religion helps
them find meaning in life
gives them words to utter when they feel
despondent
and connects them with some larger
dimension of life than the one they
experience with their senses
spirituality is not so much expressed in
a creedal statement handed down from
theologians
but it's their view about what they
might imagine the sacred to be like
spirituality can thus remain popular in
circles where participation in organized
religion has become infrequent
for instance in the survey showing
hardly any scientists attending worship
services
two-thirds nevertheless said they were
spiritual and more than a third regarded
themselves as very or moderately
spiritual
the personnel personalization
of spirituality
is associated with broader
characteristics of american religion
ones that i've described elsewhere as a
kind of grassroots theology
that focuses a lot on autobiographical
narratives
and that emphasizes spiritual journeys
and tinkering and negotiation
spiritual seekers are not uncommitted to
their quest for the sacred indeed they
often take it quite seriously
they nevertheless find answers in
multiple venues
picking and choosing what they consider
personally meaningful
rather than feeling a need to accept
entire traditions or universal truths
and two other features of contemporary
understandings of religion contribute to
the ease with which many americans
reconcile it with science
one is the idea that god is ultimately a
mystery
meaning that all teachings about god are
at best flawed or incapable of
authoritative interpretations
this view diminishes the significance of
creeds
and amplifies the importance of personal
experience
it permits believing that god created
the universe without implying that one
knows how this may have happened or even
what exactly that divine force may have
been
the other is that the meaning of sacred
texts necessarily changes as well
although the bible may be regarded as a
source of divine truth its words are
less likely to be accepted as literal
truth
and even among those who do regard it
this way the idea that it is free of
errors becomes less important
than just the fact that it's a source of
guidance and comfort
being able to relativize arguments by
defining their significance strictly in
personal terms sometimes occurs when
people talk about science as well
a thoughtful young man
named steve who participated in a recent
national study of teenagers
worried that evolution emphasizes
self-preservation
which in turn could conflict in his mind
with universalistic religious notions of
morality
but he did not worry very deeply about
this potential conflict he said because
the ideas were in his words
just fun to think about kind of
interesting because i don't know i don't
really let it bother me
and he tempers his own views about
morality and rationality by saying
let each person decide for themselves
personalization in science more often
takes a different form than it does in
religion however
it is less a matter of assuming that
science consists of private beliefs then
of believing that its purpose is to
bless all of us with personal goods
in a survey conducted for the national
science foundation for instance 86
percent of americans agreed that science
and technology are making our lives
healthier easier and more comfortable
science is in this sense pragmatic
from day to day it matters less whether
science reveals how life evolved
than that it yields vaccines and new
pharmaceuticals
that humans share a high proportion of
genetic material with other primates
is for most people a matter of idle
curiosity
it's a thought we are willing to
entertain
as long as genetic research provides
answers to riddles about birth defects
and disease
so to conclude
laments about the continuing conflicts
between science and religion
i've suggested are less interesting than
the fact that most people perceive no
contradictions between the two
to be sure many find it worrisome when
fundamentalists seek to define religious
arguments as science
and people thus consider it laudable
when theologians and scientists engage
each other in dialogue
however the value of such dialogue does
not lie in eradicating the historic
grounds on which the battles between
science and religion have been fought
it lies instead in delineating more
thoughtfully what each has to offer
and how each may influence the other
interaction of this kind requires
scientists and religious leaders to
speak beyond their own disciplines and
in ways that engage the wider public
thoughtful discussions of the
relationships between religion and
science remain rare
critics of intelligent design and
creationism
warn appropriately
that science classes are not the place
for these religious ideas to be
introduced
yet separation of church and state
generally discourages schools from
including religion in other parts of
their curriculum
meanwhile religious congregations are
unlikely venues for informed discussion
because of inadequate time
or interest
or training in science
television commentary and newspaper
editorials thus become one of the few
places in which questions about the
relationships between science and
religion appear
the reason these discussions are
difficult
is not because the public is caught up
in bitter disputes about what should be
taught in science classes
but because the both and view of science
and religion has become so familiar
when the culture tells us that all
reasonable possibilities can easily be
reconciled it's time to take another
look
religion reduced to personal opinion is
diminished nearly beyond recognition
just as science is when creature
comforts become the sole reason for
studying and supporting it
distasteful as those school board
debates may be
we might give them some credit for
articulating contradictions
too readily denied
thank you
well if i understand correctly we
have some time for
questions uh comments
yes if peop there are microphones
in each aisle so please use those
mary evelyn tucker in the institution
for social and policy studies
uh i appreciated your talk um although i
i'm not sure that i agree with this
conclusion but i actually wanted to
raise a different question and that is
um
that many of the discussions i would say
almost all
keep the framework of religion and
science within what i would really
consider christianity
and certain forms of western science
and that that's fine but it's not
defined that way and i think one of the
major problems is that we're usually
comparing science with christianity and
again fundamentalism etc so my my major
plea here is that the world's religions
should be involved should be included
and there's immense diversity and in
fact there's
larger compatibilities i would suggest
especially in some of the asian
religions
with science in its modern forms so i
would just like to um invite some
reflection on that and and that's a
point that's very well taken so i
appreciate you raising it here in fact
uh to add a footnote to your point about
the importance of world religions one of
the things that's probably going on here
in the
seeming
resurgence or upsurgence of
fundamentalist christian voices
is that they feel not only
threatened by science but threatened by
the increased religious diversity of our
society
something i've looked at in other
contexts but
people who believe for instance that
only christianity are indeed only their
version of christianity is true or the
right way or however they may frame it
are very worried about
muslims or buddhists or hindus or
for that matter immigrants of all kinds
or just the increasing diversity of the
society so there may be in this conflict
between
religion quote unquote and science a
subtext about some of these other
cultural changes that are going on
yes yeah i'm
richard prum in professor in ecology and
evolutionary biology um i had two
comments of my prompt uh responses first
i i wondered i saw
in your description of the
multi-vocal middle perhaps
a
scientific and religious commonality
could we call these people the truth
matters minority
and
how would you respond to that
and then
secondly i wonder about the the flip
side of characterizing
scientists as
not being religious
why are so few religious people going
into the sciences right and
maybe you could comment on those right
yeah
um
well your
your first point is an interesting one
about these people who are multi-vocal
in
in the middle
in the longer version of this
what i try to do is
suggest that there is kind of both good
news and bad news in
in that category in the middle
the good news being well
yes if we think of ourselves in
you know liberal education circles as
encouraging people to think and see
multiple points of view and everything
well that's precisely what we're
encouraging them to do
and so we should be glad
the bad news in that is that it is
happening so easily and so quickly
that it's
shutting off
thought and shutting off further
conversation or further engaged dialogue
because we we just
spin off a kind of easy statement about
oh well part of me thinks it is part of
me thinks that and end of discussion
okay remind me of your second one i
always forget the second one
why
why so few go into right why does it
well that's actually an interesting
question one one would assume i guess
from the
surveys of this particular study that i
mentioned
among scientists
were so few are religious that
that also means that
they were
raised
non-religious or we could assume from
those studies that apparently people who
are quite religious aren't going into
science
but i don't know that we actually have
evidence to suggest that that's
the case
uh from the broad population because
what one would
then have to do is you know track
people over time say from grade school
through high school or whatever from
lots of different backgrounds and see if
there's some
disproportionate number of say the
non-religious who become scientists and
and fewer of the religions
and
that's a reasonable assumption it's
it's one that has often
been made in these discussions about the
teaching of intelligent design
in the schools
you'll see again some of these
favorite
letter writers to the new york times
saying well
nobody from kansas is ever going to
become a scientist if that happens
well i can think of lots of reasons why
people from kansas might not become
scientists but i doubt if that's one of
one of the big ones
i graduated from ku so we're
we're together on that one but but it's
an important question yeah yes
hi my name is elizabeth i'm a first year
graduate student
um my question actually two questions i
was struck and forgive me if i don't
quote you exactly i was struck by your
thought that words were more the
province of religion numbers of science
especially later when you mentioned
that
language and culture so intimately
connect and i think of science as a huge
part of culture and also that religion
can benefit from numbers and
does and science definitely to me is an
intimate connection with words and i was
wondering if you could expand on that
yeah yeah thank you
well that struck me too that that was in
one of those quotes from a letter to the
new york times where that person
said that and
again that's a kind of easy assumption
to make
where one says well we've got let's say
literature we've got religious text on
the one side and surely those are
composed of words
whereas science well that must be all
numbers it's all math and so forth
uh that again is an example
mostly in my mind of
the the quick and easy way to find a
both and view
because i mean i suspect even that
person had they been writing a tome
rather than a short letter to the new
york times would have recognized that
well yes science is made up of words too
and numbers have a lot to do with
religion
but we need to kind of challenge those
of us who are
teachers or those of you graduate
students planning to be teachers
need to challenge those kinds of
assumptions i think in
in our students because our culture
gives us so many quick
scripts quick little phrases to resolve
this conflict that once again the
problem in my mind is that it shuts down
a thought rather than encouraging deeper
thinking let's go to you and then
hi i'm mike rhoda and
thanks for talking i found your
discussion of the motivation behind the
both hand
position interesting i wondered what you
think about a complimentary or different
explanation of the position
how about this there are many different
types of religions and on at least a few
of them there is no conflict between
science and religion maybe you know some
of the people expressing that view it
belong to those religions
um that's that's true um
uh i suspect i mean if we want to leave
it in the in the u.s context for the
time being that
uh
we know from quite a bit of evidence
that there's less
of this kind of tension
in judaism
with science
as there is in some aspects of
christianity
buddhism is kind of an interesting
case in its own right where there's a
lot of
complementarity at least in some
people's minds
although
other interpretations of buddhism
generate some conflict
some of us were having a discussion at
lunch about whether this conflict would
be
the same in islam
or not uh
once it once again one if if the idea is
to
push the people in the middle
further
so that they don't so easily say yep we
can have both then one of the ways to do
that is what your question suggests
which is to say
let's learn a little bit more about
religion and the way in which different
religious traditions have approached the
topic of course we need to encourage
people to learn more about science
but as i kind of
implied in
one of my comments about the funding
of science
we at least have ways to
try to encourage people all the way
through
elementary school high school so forth
college curricula try to encourage them
to say look you can't be educated
without some knowledge of science
we don't do that with religion
and they're good reasons why we don't
require
religion in schools
but at a great university like this one
i'm sure there are many opportunities
for students who want to to learn about
religion and probably students should be
encouraged to take more advantage of
those opportunities
i think you've partially answered my
question but
let me see if i can
communicate
a little bit about it
you talked about a survey
on
non-believers
and
leavers and agnostics
did i get my numbers correctly 38
or
non-believers 29 were agnostic
and uh
23 were
god oriented
is actually correct yeah and eight
percent were sure god exists and we're
talking about science a survey on
science and religion
right
okay so we have a set of 38
and
uh a set of 29
and a
in between set
of uh
agnostic right
and you sort of put it i'm in the middle
i find myself in that subset i find
myself right a point in the middle i
think
i'm being good to myself okay
now in line with that
i'd love to know what that survey
you know how that surgery was taken what
was the definition of science what was
the definition of religion
what was the questions that were asked
in in determining this because my
posture is that this
i don't think that people
any person is totally whatever you call
it whatever you mean it may be a
semantical problem
is religious or any person is
totally
uh
not an atheist
or
or
there's some degree of
agnostic and and where do they work and
if we're talking about science with
being educated people
how did this how did these deforming
yeah yeah okay
this was a question
uh done
uh
last year
about a year ago maybe a year and a half
ago
um
by
a social scientist named elaine eklund i
just mentioned the auspices of the
surveys in case you want to look it up
it it was a covered
i recall on
msnbc and i think maybe in usa today and
she
she at the time was teaching at rice
university and currently teaches at
suny buffalo
and there are papers now that have come
out more than just those early press
releases in case you're interested
the survey itself
was
conducted
among
the top
ranked
approximately 20
university research universities and
among the list of faculty in biology
physics and chemistry
at those universities
unlike most of the surveys that you read
about in the newspaper that maybe have a
15 response rate
this one had a 75 percent response rate
so it's pretty good in that in that
respect and it was it was from list of
people who actually
were on the faculty in
in these departments
so that was how
she
decided okay these people are scientists
incidentally she also surveyed people in
the social sciences but i focus on those
three science disciplines
it was a it was a web-based survey so
contacted people said would you be
willing to answer these questions on
on
the website
they said yes they filled out these
questions
the questions about
religion
um
focused
the main one was the one i mentioned
beliefs in god and there were about six
or seven different
responses that people could choose from
you're seeing these on your computer
screen so you can you can choose and so
if
you know if you're anywhere in the
middle if you're agnostic or a few
some of the other responses were
sometimes i do sometimes i don't believe
or
you know i'm sort of sure but not
totally sure
lots of things in the middle so those
those were the options and some of the
other questions as i mentioned
in passing
uh ask people well whether you're
religious or not whether you go to
services or not do you think of yourself
as a spiritual person now who knows what
that
means
and the ones about god are hard enough
to
to figure out
my point in mentioning those
numbers that i gave you was
just to say okay
if i'm somebody in
duluth and i'm reading
usa today
and i see
wow you know only eight percent of
scientists believe in god
and i know in my community 95 percent do
i'm going to have a certain view of
science scientist i'm going to think
well you know they're just not my type
that's that's it
um i should tell you that what
she in fairness to this person who did
the study what she's also done in the
last year and a half is
gone out to most of the campuses where
the survey was conducted and
sat down with
over i think 200 of
of these people out of something like
1400 at this point
with a tape recorder and just let them
talk and that's really more what she's
interested in these
survey results because you know as
you're pointing out who knows exactly
what people met when they responded as
they did but i'm just saying
if somebody from the public is reading
about these they're going to gain a
certain impression of scientists
physics
biology chemistry and physics yeah no i
think no they weren't primarily applied
right
that's right yep yep
how did they define religion
they asked asked question this was not a
long survey the whole thing took about
15 minutes so they asked some questions
about god
yeah yeah that was it yeah uh
i'm not sure who is next yes i'm luke
vifus i'm teaching method and theory in
religious studies um i
i was very intrigued that you said that
the funding from science was first
through major donors the medici etc and
then to the state
and um
i think it is important then also to
think
that the sciences were construed through
state interests and i think peter
gallison's work etc can can point that
the founding of the nation state and the
founding of the scientific institution
somehow went hand in hand
the flip side of that would be that also
what we call
modern religion and from modern buddhism
as backyard has shown to modern
christianity is also in this co-creation
of the nation state
and that makes me then wonder about the
multi-finality
and what i see there is actually
people in there in the frames in their
selves
mirroring the barbarian setup
of multiple
sub fears that somehow have to be
negotiated
either in the public sphere or in this
fear of one's own internal conversation
so
it doesn't strike me as surprising that
people do that and it doesn't strike me
as after the american um you know as
german i think yeah actually there are
similar attitudes it strikes me as very
verbally
so this is what would be precisely to be
expected
and that then leads me to the question
um
yes it is important to contest this
boundary
both the barbarian boundary within and
also outside and i think hillary
putnam's work nicely shows how
ideas even in the hard sciences about
what counts as a good outcome of an
experiment etc are related to ideas of
human flourishing
so i think that the task of contesting
the boundary um doesn't stop and
pointing out that individuals have these
benign barbarian multi-finalities but
rather the question
how does
this
the performance of this conflict itself
relates to the creation of the nation
state and what
what really alternative visions of being
religious
are there and how can we get to that
theoretically yeah and
i'll take that mostly as a comment i
think you stated it very well and and
it's an important point that i agree
with um
the only thing i might just suggest in
in reply is that
i'm sure you've thought about this more
than i i have so i'll just tag it for
further consideration
some of the folks who've who've come at
this question
from within the babarian tradition
of course then argued that as
the current social structure has changed
to be
less orderly or less organized around
this kind of dominant institutional
spheres that became part of the modern
nation state and becomes
more of a globalized society if you want
to use that
that language or
more of a lateral network organized
society
that may then further complicate these
understandings of the self
because we
let's say
we
we don't live in such orderly spheres if
if people ever did
we just in the religion sphere
lots of people of course
identify their religious self by
attending some kind of religious
congregation but lots of people don't
even those who who do
some of their religious cues they get
from the media and lots from their
friends and some in the workplace and
so their components the components of
their
self may be more fluid
and more mixed and therefore the
boundaries among those may be fuzzier
than in the past
that's why i think it's an ideology
right it's right yeah and that's why
maybe it turned to foucault right yes
would be helpful to actually look at
these yes but also to realize that what
we think religion is itself is part of
this ideology exactly yeah yeah thank
you
yes all right um my name is william pl
i'm a biologist
and uh i was thinking that
one of the big
one in a microcosm on university
campuses are great instances of
compatibilism
because we have
schools of science and we also on the
same campus we have divinity schools and
i'm not just talking about
departments of religion where people
study religions and social science but
whole divinity school where i guess
presumably they study aspects of god
himself
and
and in fact it occurs to me that
in cambridge right now harvard is
building the largest building
ever built in cambridge it's a 380
million dollar complex
a big cathedral for the biological
sciences
it's budding up right against the
divinity school there
in fact many of the old biology
buildings are sitting on borrowed land
it's sort of a long-term lease of
divinity school to
biology so there it seems like there's
almost a point of contact here
to what extent
how do you see the future
heading on campuses
is is there a surprising amount of
compatibilism scientists putting up with
divinity schools there and vice versa
to what extent are campuses reflective
of
you know in terms of their investment in
community schools or schools of arts and
sciences how does that
reflect on society at large
good question um
one kind of cynical question or response
i sometimes
make to those kinds of observations is
that well what is the 380 billion being
spent for well certainly not the
divinity school
as i look at my own
campus where the numbers are much
smaller
an excellent religion department which i
know from a distance being the sociology
department but
religion department is
regarded as kind of like the classics
department
something you ought to have
don't spend very much money on it don't
hire many people or encourage many
students to be involved but have it
um
well that is you're right that is one
way to have
a kind of combat compatibilism on campus
i sometimes point that out to students
and one of the ways they
they may as freshmen or sophomores
manage these multiple identities that
they've
been exposed to
is simply by going to different
buildings
to be different people
trot over to the humanities building and
study religion and they'll trot over to
the engineering quad
learn engineering
and it's not clear that they ever kind
of make the connection as they walk down
the sidewalk from one to the other
at my campus i'm in the business of
trying to mess that up
so besides being in the sociology
department i run this thing called the
center for the study of religion that
tries to get people from the sciences
and the humanities and the social
sciences and every place else to
interact
and not to major in religion or to
become religion scholars necessarily
but within their own disciplines to
think about it a little bit so for
instance in a about a month we're having
a
symposium on neuroscience and religion
and have people who do brain imaging
come and talk with people who do
philosophy of science and
you know
let them dupe it out a bit and see what
they have to say to each other
that certainly can't substitute for the
deep knowledge that has to occur within
disciplines but i think it
is a kind of layer of the educational
experience that's valuable
yeah i'm robert wyman from biology so we
continue the harvard story
sorry i was told when i was there many
times i heard it i'm not sure it's true
is that at the same time probably the
previous questioner was talking about
the harvard was building its first
accelerator and it just happened to be
near the
near the science campus there it just
happened to be angled so the out outport
was directed at the biology buildings
biologists said no no no
what to do we'll just tilt it a few
degrees toward the divinity school they
won't know
so
harvard's one icon the new york times is
another and the new york times has been
following this debate
moderately and every so often even quote
uh from some of the creationists
especially that
that are interesting
and uh i've been sort of paying
attention to what the creationists
actually say which is what many people
in this debate don't do
and one of the quotes was a couple of
the quotes were really quite remarkable
so one was a debate between creationists
and uh
darwinians
and they interviewed i think a minister
coming out of this debate and he was
just angry as heck
and he says the whole purpose of this of
this
debate is to come closer to god and we
didn't make any progress
on that
that's a short quote another one they
quote minister giving going to one of
these meetings
and then uh going to on sunday to his
congregation
and uh
giving sort of a report of it and he
says to his congregation i heard really
interesting things and it's very clear
to me now that the choice is really
simple
the scientists are saying that earth is
a
rock in a cold black universe and you
know some zillions of years ago some
slime sort of woke up and
slithered around and after a lot of
generations it became a monkey in them
you
and you know there is no god you know
when you die the worms eat you again and
you know you can believe that he says on
the other hand you can believe that you
know there's a god in heaven and he
loves you and he created this garden of
eden of an earth for you and created you
in his image and he gave his only
begotten son to save you and loves you
and will forgive you and take you up to
heaven etc and he will say
you have a choice you can believe a or
you complete b
and if you read through
a lot of these quotes what
comes strongly through to me anyway
is that truth at least truth as
scientists understand it is the utter
irrelevance
to
people who are deeply religious that is
not the issue
and so when scientists talk to them and
i think this is part of the answer
but there are shit's totally crossing in
the night scientists go and they go to
these debates i'm like i must admit i
came here to find out is there anything
new on
on the truth-ish
you know and uh
scientists come to these things and try
to say well what we say is true
and
you know and then of course several
paragraphs later the scientist comes and
says
well of course we don't have truth all
we have is really falsifiability
and all that we can say is well you know
what we currently believe uh fits with
the evidence so of course the the
people go away and say all right you
don't even know whether what you're
saying is true or not so i'm not going
to say what we're saying is not true
and
what i'm saying i think something you
left out and one of the reasons i think
that people might be able to
encompass
both of these things easily at the same
time is that
all of us carry around very very
different and contradictory ideas of
truth i do this with a with a science
for non-scientist class i just ask the
kids on the first day to define truth
and half of them come up with it's
conventional it's by definition it's
what everybody accepts and the others
it's demonstrable by experiment etc etc
that that there's sort of a unique truth
or this kind of a conventional truth and
almost all of us use the word truth and
at least those two senses at different
times in our conversation and i think
most uh
humans everywhere do that and therefore
scientific truth is in one pot and
although we use the same word it has an
opposite meaning religious truth is in
some other part
yeah
thank you
professor i'm leo hickey i'm part of the
geology and geophysics department
and
here we go and uh i think your talk was
a bit paradoxical
because we've built this as a
discussion of the conflict between
science and religion and
if i were to fly over your talk at about
15 000 feet i might think that there was
virtually no conflict among the general
population
and i
just to stir things up a bit and maybe
continue a bit from where bob left off
i think that's probably not true and and
it really in a way doesn't matter
what the general population thinks
somebody here
mentioned the fact that there was
western science and as if there was an
eastern science
science is a profoundly western
operation that has been transplanted
around the world it's a universal human
operation now at which all of us do as
well but it originally and in its
genesis was a western operation and with
profoundly uh was a product of
judeo-christian hellenistic tradition uh
which looked at progressiveness and
progressivity uh and in fact i often
tell my students that uh
western civilization and the
enlightenment was the only time
in which fossils
which are the rock record of past life
where the realization that these things
were once living life forms this is the
only civilization which ever realized
that the except for the greeks who had a
bit of a dim glimmer of this
and
the the point here is that science
itself
has been a process
over the years which has displaced the
centrality
of the human divine relationship
gradually and has put that aside
it has
really engendered profound questions as
bob mentioned about the meaning of human
life and human beings and these
questions have disturbed
those who think deeply about them
and the shock waves of this have visited
themselves upon the population as a
whole
and we now have a progressivist view
and a
an evidentiary view
that was not shared by
my religious compatriots
six centuries ago and with uh religion
in general
so
i think
there is a conflict it isn't necessarily
resolvable
uh and i think one of the things we have
to do is
see where some of the profound lessons
for a human being and for the seeking of
truth come out of this in the end but i
i do want to emphasize that i i did
think that
perhaps
taking a sort of a general average
sociological view might not really
i think there is a conflict i think and
it's quite apparent that from the very
beginning of the adoption of the
evolutionary paradigm those like thomas
huxley were quite aware of the
sociological implications of this and
we're using science and the scientific
view as a weapon against the established
religious and hierarchical
framework that they found themselves in
and this has continued to this day and
it is a cause of considerable uneasiness
on the part of the social structure
those who arbitrate the
the social uh maurice as well as the
religious establishment thank you
well thank you um
your comment reminds me or makes me
think that maybe i did a better job in
the second half of my talk than in the
first half because the
the first half of my talk was basically
to
say
what you said very eloquently
yes
there are good reasons for conflict here
you've mentioned some of the scientific
or epistemological reasons which i
mentioned just in
passing i also tried to emphasize even
some within our institutions and the way
we live our lives
yeah when you look at all of those
things you sort of look at these both
and people and say
it's just more complicated than than
that there really ought to be more
conflict than
than we see even so i think i'm agree
agreeing with you
kevin hi my name is evan baer and i'm a
student at the divinity school and i'd
be very curious to hear if you've looked
at
the growth of christian worldview
education and looked at um or for
example what do you know about what
churches for example are doing to help
the members of their church think
through questions of science i know in
areas of vocation and economy
even some international human rights and
missions kind of work that's happening
among churches our church is at all
trying to bridge the gap to science are
there christian authors who are writing
on these subjects that's penetrating
i would just think of you know if rick
warren wrote a book on science it would
have a huge impact on how mainstream
america thinks about issues of science
i think that something that needs to be
done desperately needs to happen but
isn't happening very much yet
there are probably things i don't know
about especially at the grassroots but
as i look at the literature being
produced
kind of from the religion side or the
theology side
kind of broad religion and science
engagement
you know you see some of the same names
over and over and over again
and
you look at the latest book and it looks
an awful lot like the previous book or
in fact the 10 before that
and the science that's being cited
usually isn't anything since
1980 if then
which makes me think
yes there's room
for people who know the science well
enough
and
have enough understanding of religion or
theology or however they frame it
to deal with it from that side
but it's
it's not happening
and i don't see it happening very much
in
congregation
christian congregations is one of the
ones i have in mind
there are a few
i happen to belong to one that
because it's
literally you know the one i'm talking
about literally on the princeton campus
it's able to bring over scientists and
historians of science and so forth to
give lectures and to have discussions
you know
that's that's one of the places where
this kind of discussion can
happen
but there just aren't
many places that have the kind of
resources to really do it well and
you know you mentioned rick warren uh
yeah that that would be great if you
know somebody who has
the audience this is the purpose-driven
life
author 25 million copies or so somebody
who has an audience like that
could do that
and probably could be because he has all
the staff and the huge church and
undoubtedly has scientists who go to his
church knows his church and so forth
i doubt if that's going to happen in
in his case
why not
one of the things that that's happening
in the kind of larger world of
religion with
the clergy who have influence is that
they are so driven by
numbers
drawing in large numbers of people
building up big
congregations
having a television ministry or in the
best of cases as in rick warren spending
a lot of their time
helping
rwanda rebuild itself
laudable
but the
the average
congregation doesn't have much of a
kind of built-in incentive
to deal with this
quest with these questions
so i think it
the places where these discussions are
going to happen
certainly going to have to happen on
campuses if they happen at all
hopefully they'll also happen
on divinity school campuses and seminary
campuses
and in the best situations they're going
to happen
in the world of journalism or on
television or on npr or whatever it may
be
um
i think as in so many issues this
unfortunately this is just one of the
big issues that we're dealing with in
our society but as with so many of them
and maybe because we're bombarded with
lots of different things to think about
and worry about
it's just so easy to kind of brush off
this
topic and say
oh yeah a little science little religion
you know that's fine with me and not go
any deeper
we are
out of
time am i right we should take a break
i'll be around if
you have other questions thank you
you